there was this whole thing where richard
has ants in his house so the other day
Richard is convinced there was an ant
living in his ear Oh
so let's say you really did believe that
the best thing to do would be what right
so Richard comes in and he says to Steve
nawicki
can you examine me see if there's an ant
living in my ear and I'm thinking that
poor ants if there is one in there
NOAA key declared him clean so that was
the end of that so he doesn't have
antennas ear he's broken toe so he Bruns
he's a big runner yeah when he was
training for the marathon he had mangled
his toe so bad that they told me at the
cut at all Oh get out of here he doesn't
care he's like I don't need a tow well
yeah just lop it off and someone said
well you know can't affect your
equilibrium he goes woods are there he's
gonna run a half marathon in a week with
the bad these feet are so disgusting
like every toe is all bloody and so
clearly you know I'm right socks and the
doctor told him that the toe will
balloon up after the marathon like you
don't think you need your toe you
wouldn't be you wouldn't be upset if you
didn't ever talk no it [ __ ] me up
probably yeah
are you wearing the right kind of shoes
because that just doesn't sound right
well I actually hit my toe on something
and broke it it wasn't because of the
shoes no my little toes are turning kind
of sideways but again I think that's a
shoe issue yeah I mean I I get super
wide shoes for that what's going on with
that house you advanced ah there's some
ants and what happened how did you think
there was an ant in your ear I tickled
real bad like felt like something was
crawling it well that's probably because
you don't clean your ears you know truth
probably the wax trying to get out
because there's no more room with it
there's probably his brains right brain
leaking out no but uh yes I went to dr.
Steve nawicki why would you ask Steve
nowicki to check your bed for ants
Steve's a genius he's good at everything
I trust eh Steve could you check my ass
for the hemorrhoids and worms I think
there's a mouse in my butt
sleeve you got your doctor flashlight
and Steve fixes my phone he does
everything I trust him yeah well Steve
told me all of your toenails look bloody
and weird what I did I was walking
barefoot in our house and I smacked my
foot up against the pipe and now the toe
is broken and you're just gonna run on
it yeah it's fractured and must hurt
like [ __ ]
it hurts pretty bad and you're gonna do
that huh I have to it's like our
favorite mayor half marathon of the year
before you know it it'll be here once
you let your toe heel up you don't think
like that right no no I
plus I'll feel like I've really
accomplished something if I run but I
mean you're limping right let me see you
walk look at ya yeah mark he's Lee
Cleese waddling like a penguin no wonder
he doesn't care for his equilibrium goes
I'm telling you I never had it